as we speak there's kind of a battle
going on
over
whether joe rogan should be on spotify
and allowed to spread scientific
misinformation
in particular there's a guy named robert
malone that's talking about
that that's making a case against of
at least against the covet vaccine and
so on
so outside of the specifics of this
person
in this
battle of
scientific ideas
that are sometimes tied up with ideology
in our modern world
what do you think is the role like who
gets the sensor decide what is
misinformation or information
should we let
ideas
fly in the scientific realms of
scientific ideas or should we try to get
it under control like what which way
obviously all
uh approaches will go wrong in some ways
which is more likely to go wrong
uh one where you try to get a hold of
like all right this is a viral
thing
and it doesn't
fit with scientific consensus so we
should probably like try to like quiet
it down a little bit or do you let it
all just fly and let the ideas battle do
you think about this kind of stuff in
the context of
of uh history well that used to be a
million dollar
question of course now it's a
multi-billion dollar question not
trillion yeah um
we're talking
about powerful internet platforms
becoming essentially publishers
and publishers can't say whatever they
want
there are limits
uh there's you know they can't yell fire
in a crowded theater
but there are uh
there's a kind of social responsibility
that is there and i know
some of these i don't know a lot about
this topic but i know there are large
some of the large platforms do have
dedicated offices
to
trying to rein in misinformation
as you would expect any publisher to do
you can't just let anything fly in
time magazine or
or the new york times
either they have there are all kinds of
codes of ethics and legal obligations so
i uh i'm a fan of the efforts or i think
some of the large internet platforms
should be congratulated at least for
trying to make an effort to rein in
misinformation it's going to be
difficult and there the mistakes are
going to be made but it can't be a
let everything fly kind of situation but
when i watch
unfortunately
the pressure these platforms feel
to identify and to censor misinformation
that pressure is uh
ideological in nature currently
so if you just objectively look there's
a certain political lien to people that
are
pressing on the censorship of the
misinformation which makes me very
uncomfortable
because now there's an ideology to
labeling something as misinformation as
opposed to
kind of uh
having a you know value
less
evaluation of what is true or not and
you also have to acknowledge
that it says something
that there's a very large number of
people
that um
for example follow robert malone or
follow people i mean what does that say
about society yeah and that there's a
deeper
lesson in there that's not just about
blocking misinformation
it's uh distrust
in science and institutions distrusting
leaders like it feels like you have to
fix that
and then censorship of misinformation is
not going to be fixing that it's only
going to like
uh throw gasoline on the fire
you got to put out the fire
well that's that's certainly possible
yeah i mean the uh
i think
people are distrustful of certain
institutions and not others
right and uh i think a lot of distrust
is is good
uh i'm not a conspiracy theorist but i
do know there have been a lot of
conspiracies
and
that
you know people work behind scenes to do
powerful bad things and
that's what needs to be exposed the
other thing i worry about which is
relevant to your question again it's a
billion or a trillion dollar question is
uh we're ki i think in a world of kind
of flattening where
all news or all information or all data
is kind of equal in some way and so you
get the twitter verse
going and
it doesn't matter if it's peer-reviewed
or it doesn't matter if it's
been supported by evidence it's just
you know a kind of
outburst
it's it's interesting to contrast it
with say a hundred years ago i mean what
would
a crazy person or a
a flat earther or anything
what
venue would they have i mean maybe they
could go to a church or someplace i mean
uh
so now we have this in these empowering
engines
then that's what's new historically is
that
basically anyone can have a blog or a
a twitter
feed and
that is new and so that is
you can think of it also as a kind of
clutter so it's a kind of a radical
democracy in a way that kind of the one
of the weaknesses of democracy is if
everyone has an equal voice
and if everyone has equal power
so there's of course a flip side to that
where everyone has equal power it forces
the the people
who are quote-unquote experts to be
better communication i think people like
scientists are just like upset that they
have to do like better work at
communicating now they used to be lazy
and you could just like say i have a phd
therefore everyone listened to me now
they have to actually convince people
like you have to convince people that
the earth is round you can't just say
the earth is wrong that's it you have to
like show you have to uh make
like i mean not the earth is round part
but yeah things like that you have to
actually be a great communicator and
great do great lectures do documentaries
and so on and to battle those ideas
and then also to defend
the sort of uh
the people labeled as crazy
you know in nazi germany
if you were protesting against
uh some of the uses of science of
medicine
to commit atrocities you would also be
labeled crazy yeah so well those voices
are important yeah there's so many good
points there the
on the scientists becoming good
communicators
the history of scientists becoming bad
communicators has a history
and
the last original contribution to
science
written entirely in the form of a poem
is uh bufol's loves of the plants
and
following that in the 18th century you
get the uglification of science the
deliberate uglification of science with
the idea being that if you are clear and
if you speak beautifully if you write
beautifully you're hiding something
you're covering over
the truth with
flowers
and decorations and and
scents and pleasant odors and so
uh
you get this scientific paper format you
know introduction discussion
methods conclude you know results
conclusions
and it's it's kind of policed in this uh
inhumane non-humanistic kind of
rhetorical way and that's a big problem
and so you get
that combined with just the rise of the
research lab and the ever narrower
widget builders the cogs in the machine
it's not surprising that people might
not trust certain aspects of that that
combined with the dirty laundry history
of a lot of science
uh that you did have you know the
requirement that uh at auschwitz that
people be you know that that physicians
supervise the killings
uh
you know
the the horrors of you know tuskegee and
and all kinds of other things or even
something like the atom bomb which is
arguably more neutral at least
but nonetheless horrific and so
it's not surprising that uh a lot of
people don't trust science and a lot of
science shouldn't be trusted right
there's science and then there's science
so there's a long history of dirty
bad science
that you don't solve just by saying we
should have trusted it
you